I think we need a more open system I'm
perfectly willing to accept a system
that encourages third parties to come
into the race don't underestimate the
third parties however George Bush would
not be elected president of the United
States if it were not for Ralph Nader
Bill Clinton would not have been elected
president of the United States if it
were not for Ross Perot so they may not
win the presidency but they can
certainly have an impact third parties
now your question is a little different
and that is should we be more open to
them I think the answer is yes we should
I'm a party member but I understand that
people can be terribly disappointed by
the performance of the political parties
I'm disappointed by the performance of
my own party my choice has been and it's
not the choice everyone would make but
my choice has been to try to work within
the party to strengthen it a lot of
people make that choice a lot of people
say that's not the way to go that
parties are too unacceptable as they are
I don't quarrel with that decision I
think it's a reasonable position it was
not the position I adopted but that
doesn't make it wrong it could be the
right way to go we do have to emphasize
the fundamental values of our system
tolerance rule of law compassion and
that leaves a lot of room for change and
we must always have in our mind a
receptivity to changing our structures
and not think that because we've had a
two-party system for lo these many years
that's the only way that the country
works the record the historical record
obviously is not very encouraging for
the third parties but who knows what the
breakthrough might come and how it might
come III don't know I can't foresee that
but I wouldn't exclude it happening
either
look what Ross Perot did he talked about
the budget deficit
neither current party candidate of the
major parties was talking about the
budget deficit he came into the campaign
not only did he affect the outcome of
the election but he put on the national
agenda the budget deficit third parties
make contributions even when they don't
win elections it may come that there'll
be an issue at some point that will
propel a third third party into victory
who knows I can't foresee that I don't
think I'd predict it in the next one or
two presidential elections but I've been
fooled a lot of times in the process and
it could happen
you